Freunde ein großartiger Tag erwartet und
wir werden uns durch ganz Berlin Essen
bei den vielleicht besten Läden der
Stadt und als allererstes müssen wir
frühstücken und dafür gehen wir zu Brady
44 los geht's
[Musik]
also schauen wir uns mal die Karte an
charakteristisch sind hier die
ex-sandwiches in einem Brioche Brot
gefüllt mit was auch immer man möchte
zwischen 7 und 10 €, also relativ fair
preislich auf jeden Fall ein guter Ort
um seinen Tag zu starten wir schauen uns
erstmal um dann stellen wir uns was
leckeres und lassen uns gut geht ich
liebe dich
sieht sehr gut aus
da wird man wach oder
es sieht wirklich wunderschön aus soft
scrabbelt Ex liebe ja so ein ganz
weiches Rührei Bacon dazu das kann nur
lecker sein und ich habe ganz hohe
erwarte ich wusste ehrlich das ist so
gut aussehen würde ich habe natürlich
wie immer die Spots in der Stadt in der
ich mich nicht so gut auskenne heißt
selbst ausgewählt halt über Empfehlung
aber ich gebe mir immer große Mühe
deshalb bin ich mir sicher alles was
kann sich wirklich sehen lassen aber vor
allem
so gut ich habe die ganze Zeit schon an
Ex lad in LA gedacht so der Laden der so
externe macht zum Frühstück die
Eier nicht so Butter aufgeschlagen ist
auch so ein leichte Ratscher mal oder
dabei das Banne selbst unfassbar buttrig
sehr wolkig also es schmeckt wirklich
unglaublich gut durch die Bank alles
hätte alles verschmilzt unfassbar weich
lecker fluffig es ist richtig richtig
gut also richtig richtig richtig gut
wenn ich hier leben würde ich würde das
ständig essen kein Spaß also danach kann
ich mir vorstellen
kannst danach jetzt wahrscheinlich
keinen Marathon laufen aber es geht dir
gut das kommt von gut das an einem
Sonntag und der Tag wird perfekt im Bett
liegen chillen beste Leben sehr sehr
krass hätte ich nicht gedacht und ich
habe sogar noch eins probieren
Knoblauch und Bacon zum Frühstück dann
Ende der Tag bevor angefangen hat aber
wir probieren das ganze
noch nie gesehen so mit diesen fetten
Brioches was mich ernst gerade wundert
wie weich die sind heute wird ein guter
Tag wirklich unglaublich gut eine echte
zehn von zehn von Herzen Marie testet
heute die veganen Spots bist Du auch
zufrieden unnormal
ein bisschen was anderes als
das was Kaffee wirklich auch sehr gut
eine Sache finde ich sticht noch heraus
ich habe nach dem Top food Spots gefragt
so viele Leute haben mir ein Frühstück
sogar
win ab zum nächsten Mal
willkommen zum zweiten Spot wir stehen
vor konopkes Imbiss
[Musik]
hier haben wir Sie also eine schwierige
Frage welche Currywurst zeigt man in
Berlin bei Berliner Currywurst ist
natürlich fast so bekannt wie Berlin
selbst und unsere weiß auf knoppke
gefallen Ilia einen Freund aus Berlin
nur Berlin
das ist original direkt unter dem
Bahngleisen und man sieht auch die
Schlange gibt ihm recht wir sind auf
jeden Fall einige Leute die aussehen als
würden gute Currywurst gibt und hier
haben wir sie also sie sieht nicht nach
viel aus aber ich hoffe sie schmeckt
nach viel was ich sehr interessant finde
du kannst hier nicht aussehen willst du
Schaf willst du Atom Schaf willst du
erdnuss-soße nein du kriegst einfach
eine Currywurst kannst du normal nehmen
kannst du vegan nehmen ich würde sagen
nicht lange schnacken Kopf in Nacken die
Haut außen sieht schon so ein bisschen
über analysieren nicht wir lassen den
Geschmack entscheiden
es ist eine geile Currywurst ne also ich
glaube mehr muss es auch nicht sein
Curry 36 klar keine Frage kenne ich auch
hatte ich auch überlegt das ist halt so
weniger so ein Tipp deshalb sind wir
hier gelandet die Currywurst schmeckt
super gut die Soße ist auch sehr lecker
so die Wurst ist knackig super soft
innen drin ich muss euch nicht viel
erzählen was du gut Currywurst ausmacht
aber wenn ihr in Berlin eine Currywurst
essen wollt seid ihr hier auf jeden Fall
einer guten Adresse außenrum fahren die
Bahn der Verkehr das ist hektisch am
besten ist einfach im Stehen schnell
zack zack auf nach Hause weg irgendwie
Pommes Test auch genau diese sein müssen
wir probieren einfach mal schnell die
vegane Variante
war sehr gelungen ist die Haut an der
veganen Version weil die echt knusprig
ist innen drin auch lecker also hier ist
für jeden was dabei hier gibt's eine
gute Berliner Currywurst deshalb
bescheid wir gehen zum nächsten Spot der
ist gar nicht weit von hier
nächster Spot Ski so Burger mein
persönlicher Favorit und warum das sehen
wir jetzt los geht's
[Musik]
zufällig entdeckt vor fünf Jahren oder
so in Berlin war und ich habe einen
Bulgari Burger bestellt und ich schwöre
euch als ich damals in Berlin war ich
war ganz alleine
oder so und ich bin vier Tage lang jeden
Tag zu Burger gegangen ich meine es
komplett Ernst ich bin komplett hängen
geblieben und jedes Mal schmeckt mir
wieder genauso gut und was sind so
besonders macht zeige ich euch jetzt
gleich
endlich ist es soweit Leute allein
dieser Duft der aufsteigt das hat was
sie mir ausgelöst also wirklich das war
so vor allen food Videos und bevor ich
so ein größeres Interesse habe und ich
habe Gefühle für diesen Burger er ist
nicht normal wir haben hier einen
gedämpftes Band mit schwarzen
Sesamkörnern welches super weich ist
unbeschreiblich innen drin haben wir das
Bulgari beef also diese rinderstreifen
oben rote Soße die so sehr pikant ist
ein bisschen Blattspinat ist dabei und
leicht gelbliche Soße das ist wirklich
das ist der einzige Spot der von mir ist
ohne Berliner zu sein kann ich sagen
dass das hier eine der besten Sachen ist
man in Berlin essen kann ich glaube es
gibt Shisha Burger auch in Hamburg aber
diese Art von Burger ist halt nicht so
populär so ich weiß nicht ob wir das
erfunden haben oder ob sie das noch
woanders gibt er sieht halt auch
wirklich schon aus ne ich gehe jetzt
rein und danach muss Erik probieren weil
ich will wissen was er dazu sagt
[Musik]
so lecker ich liebe diesen Burger ich
habe auch jeden jeden den ich mag der
mit mir in Berlin habe ich hierher
gefahren sogar Ilja den mag ich doch
nicht aber sogar
gebracht ja sehr lecker
deswegen
auch diese rote Soße die so kräftig
schmeckt dann dieses quasi während man
es einfach nur hält und zusammen
schmilzt es ist unglaublich
das sind große Töne die du gerade
verloren hast also wirklich gegessen
die intensiv
das einzige was er mit einem Burger zu
tun hat ist das dass das Brot und
Fleisch ist aber alles andere diese
ganzen Geschmacksrichtungen hast du noch
nie einen Burger geschmeckt aber die
sind genau richtig da drin ist normal
unnormal lecker habe ich zu viel
versprochen noch ein bitte
schönster Manager von Justin Deutschland
mein persönlicher Favorit in Berlin aber
es gibt ein innen sehr sehr viele
Anreize in Favoriten und ihr habt die
mir so oft geschickt ich weiß zweiter
Bürger das ist ja kein klassischer
Burger wir fahren jetzt zu Goldies
und hier sind wir jetzt wir haben Glück
dass ein Dienstag ist ich glaube der
Laden ist so im Hype dass man sonst
eigentlich immer warten muss jetzt
gerade zum Glück nicht spricht vieles
dafür dass ich ihn richtig guter Burger
ist nicht nur die Meinung von Holle von
Lukas von vielen anderen die benutzen
amerikanische Bands Markus potato Roll
sehr sehr geil machen die Patties so
super dünn super schönes matcht wie wir
Smash Burger macht sie häufig für mich
selbst und habe noch nie so ein richtig
guten in Deutschland in dem Restaurant
gegessen meine große Hoffnung ich weiß
zweiter Burger Spot aber der andere war
was ganz anderes und ich musste euch
einfach beide zeigen deshalb gucken wir
mal rein
[Musik]
ich habe mir wie so oft nicht viel
angeschaut es sieht krass aus es sieht
sehr sehr krass aus das perfekte Brownie
sieht sehr sehr gut aus der Käse
schmilzt so ins Petty rein so wie man es
kennt wie man es liebt auf jeden Fall so
ein Burger und wie man mehrere essen
kann also ich finde schon mal dass man
sich die Mühe macht und diese
amerikanischen Bands importiert dickes
Plus der beste Burger den ich bisher
gegessen habe war wahrscheinlich der bei
Burger in Los Angeles sehr sehr krass
sieht dem ganz ähnlich ich werde euch
mal hier ein Bild ein wir hatten ein
bisschen anderes
Marke so ja das Vertrieb und ich gehe
einfach direkt rein komm
wow wie viel Macht der richtig
sehr viel
ja wirklich schmecken überhaupt nicht
vegan
besser Veganer Burger den ich hatte ja
ich habe einen guten Vergleich weil ich
habe mehrmals in der letzten Woche auch
für ein tik tok letztens Oklahoma Union
Burgers gemacht die so ganz dünnes Match
und ich bin auch der Meinung dass ich
ganz gut zu Hause bekommen das hat aber
noch mal ein anderes Level also deren
Grill wird einfach heißer kontinuierlich
heiß so die Kruste die das Fleisch
bekommt ist Killer das ist ein Burger
den man so nicht bekommt ich weiß
zumindest keinen anderen Ort in
Deutschland wo man den einfach so
bestellen kann ganz kurz für Leute nicht
kennen dieser Burger macht alles richtig
was ist Smash Burger machen soll der
verschmilzt so eine wenn man
food denkt dann denkt man an sowas sehr
krasser Burger vielleicht der beste den
ich in Deutschland gegessen habe absolut
verdient hier in dieser Liste schau dort
an die Jungs schon getestet haben weiter
geht's zum letzten Sport mit einer
weiteren Sache die nicht fehlen darf in
Berlin
natürlich darf ein Döner nicht fehlen
ein Berliner Döner ein gemüsedöner wir
sind vor rühren viele kennen den Laden
vielleicht von Eli er meinte wenn du
nach Berlin kommst musst du hier meinen
Döner essen deshalb machen wir das heute
ein Berliner Döner muss in der Berliner
futur sein ich persönlich liebe Berliner
Döner und deshalb freue ich mich jedes
Mal wenn ich hier bin Döner zu essen und
nicht nur Eli sagt dass er gut ist 4,8
von 5 Sterne aus über 8000 Bewertung ich
bin gespannt was auf mich zukommt ganz
klassisch beenden wir den Tag in Berlin
mit einem Döner normalerweise nach dem
Feiern gehen je nachdem wir den ganzen
Tag gegessen haben aber ein Döner passt
immer gehen wir rein und holen uns ein
[Musik]
eine Sache möchte ich noch sagen wir
haben natürlich verschiedenste Läden die
eigentlich verdient hätten aufgenommen
zu werden nicht aufnehmen können weil es
einfach ein absolutes Überangebot in
Berlin gibt ich hatte auch Eli gefragt
welcher Laden drin sein muss nach seiner
Meinung er hat gesagt Grill Royal so ein
Steakhouse aber das passt einfach nicht
mehr in diesen Tag rein so ich wollte
unbedingt Döner haben deshalb will
Royale Empfehlung und einladen den ich
leider auch nicht testen konnte ist
Urania in der Nähe von Goldie Smash
Burger einladen der eine gehobene Küche
bietet die Empfehlung war von rechts
zwei sterneküchen das Viergang entenmenü
nur das jetzt mal gehört habt vielleicht
hat sie auch sowas Lust habt ist das was
für euch aber jeden Moment kommt jetzt
der Döner ich freue mich darauf und dann
schlafen danke dir danke schön okay im
Vorfeld hätte vielleicht gesagt dass das
ist auch dass ich mich am meisten freue
bei den guten Sachen die wir gestern gar
nicht unmöglich behaupten es war
wirklich so krank was wir alles heute
hatten aber in Berliner Döner setzt
allem die Krone auf wie gesagt ich setze
große Stücke darauf Worte aber auch zum
Beispiel von Shirin David superhahn also
ihren Liebling noch mal getestet ist auf
dem Gemüse dünner auch sehr sehr krass
ich persönlich habe früher ich weiß
nicht ob der immer noch gut ist ja hier
in Berlin immer Döner 44 in Kreuzberg
gegessen war auch sehr sehr krank aber
ja ich merke schon das Brot ist knusprig
wenn mit Sesam obendrauf
ich vermisse dich einfach
geborener aber es gibt keine
vergleichbaren Döner in Köln also es
gibt Berliner Döner sind einfach die
Macht Alter
Brötchen knusprig die Soßen
Knoblauchsoße beste Leben und das
Fleisch es gibt hier nur Hähnchen
Fleisch und sehr sehr saftig 5,80 €
mittlerweile auch ein relativ normaler
dönerpreis geworden
so diese Gemüse Variation im Gemüse
Kebap ist auch sehr sehr gelungen ich
habe den ganzen Tag gegessen eigentlich
nicht mehr so hungrig aber es schmeckt
trotzdem krass gut ich bin nicht
derjenige um zu beurteilen Döner in
Berlin ist ich weiß dass es ein sehr
krasser Döner ist ich glaube das waren
auch sehr krasse foodsports 5 an der
Zeit ein paar Empfehlungen habe ich noch
gegeben wenn euch das Video gefallen hat
lasst gerne ein Like da abonniert den
Kanal und sagt wenn ihr Bock auf part 2
habt ich habe auf jeden Fall Bock Berlin
wir sehen uns bestimmt wieder peace sein